welcome back to Glamour with me Josh
Smith and today we are joined by love
islands Amy ha
but how are you good Huntley the best
decision for me to leave when I do yes
and was exactly the right time like if
I'd left before or after I've been
horrible then I left on good terms of
run building foundations for friendships
yes and just got get home try and he'll
enjoy this like new weird life I've got
now that seed we stood up into the
speech I was embarrassed like I was
crying so much I think the whole nation
was as well I just need to know talk me
through how you came to that decision
process and I need to know did you
rehearse the speech because the speech
was really damn good when we'd been
almost done the night before I was a bit
annoyed that we hadn't been don't yeah
well yeah and I fill up when you get to
the point where you wish you were going
home maybe it's time to go home but I
thought no you know my friends have
saved me I need to stay you know I'm
fine love again donor but so i sat there
listening to a conversation the next day
and somewhere above all listen to the
boys talk about life telling the girls
oh nothing no notice they both in the
conversation so like are more what I
told him I loved hearing
yeah I just thought like I'm not ready
to find something new I'm ready to watch
him find someone new it's probably time
for me to go it was from the heart
believe me and obviously it was really
hard for me because all my friends at
around I had luckily had the boys
directly in front of me who were all
just like what and then I had Anna
crying her eyes out but sighted me and I
just thinking really really confused and
I could just hear more me quickly cry
whilst I'm trying to pack my case
everyone else too cried and I was fine
and then when I left at the door
everyone else crying I was fine
did you cry on the way home was that it
the emotions were done after that why do
you think that is my client in the film
yeah you tip thanks go little out what
works for odd one of the most amazing
things you've done is you picked your
own mental house over fame would you say
that was a decision you definitely made
a hundred percent if you're current on
television more followers love you stay
in I went in there to find love I found
love
it went horrendously wrong yeah I didn't
want to find love again so I needed to
come out like if I'd stayed and had to
watch more cracking on the Coyotes and
she'd said that the gloves are off I
didn't want to sit there and be privy to
all of that yeah and just absolute have
a heart ripped out again three weeks
what was your journey like with your
mental health while you're in there for
the beginning to the end
a lot of times you think while you're in
there I'm a real over thinking anyway
and you know when you say something off
the car off and then you've got two
hours to sit by the pool and think about
it in why I said that you're like this
people would say this about it I did use
a psychic about
twelve times two worked out I also use
it when when times are still good but I
still use it then just because it's such
a great do you feel more mentally strong
now leaving a hundred percent because as
well I think so much is made about
reality TV show and mental health now
there's so many stories that come out
about there do you feel like the show is
making commitment to the contestants
mental health a hundred percent from the
minute I auditioned until like forever
basically might have the best support
network ever if you're gonna go through
heartbreak the best place to do it is
the loved one I'm Philip but notice
you've got although it's on TV isn't
ideal
you've got the production team you put
the site team but the welfare take
mmm-hmm you've got your fellow Islanders
I have like 14 months of practice I
ought to care and then if I need
anything else after that I people always
find them but we're going in there's
normal people and coming out in this
whole new world and whether or not like
it's actually any big thing to you talk
about sometimes you need to talk about
your life changing you're out now and
you've come out to like a massive social
media following which is also quite
scary amazing thing both for the same
time and obviously annoyingly we live in
this time of social media where there's
so much negativity is you know how have
you doubt we've seen the negativity that
you probably had to go through and I
think your parents obviously came out
and released that statement about saying
you've got to remember this is a real
person when people were saying negative
things about you have you doubt with
hearing about that star I typed in a me
heart love Ireland and the first search
result that came up when Twitter was
only heart love Ireland ugly 190 tweets
now the old me was really clicked on it
and read them all and prized but did it
look Leah I'm not interested in knowing
what was said about me I have now got so
much positivity I read it I laugh about
it
that's the best way forward you gotta
laugh it off because otherwise it's just
gonna become overwhelming right and I
understand that you know it's been like
a week and I understand in a year's time
I'm being constantly told it might be
hard like I say I have got the support
that I won in team so love white unless
you provided us with social media
training which is another great amazing
and it was it was wasn't like we all
thought it was gonna be Noah and this is
the right time to post this how much
should be done it's not that at all it's
looking after our well be and I'm
protecting us you know don't read trolls
block people if even a really awful
important to Instagram
they taught me as well that you can put
words on comments everyone keeps
commenting Sam I'm deleting all the
negative comments imagine not it's clear
to show up up yeah because I look like
fat ugly and like all different work
yeah like because I think why would I
have them on there what's the point it's
like emotional self harm isn't it it's
hilarious but then all these tropes that
they're trying to they're getting at me
and actually they're just piss me the
wind the joke is on them yes it's
actually really amazing to see how
empowered you are because I was worried
that you're gonna come out and you're
gonna be quite fragile but you're
literally the complete opposite to that
yeah I my mom keeps on I went in a girl
came a lady I think as well there's so
much made around love island and
feminism and you touched on the thing
about body image and how people were
saying these nasty things about your
body image on social media they can't
win every other year they're like they
all look like models they are not the
same you know and why can't we have
normal people in them I mean I would say
that I'm mercifully normal obviously
I've got that belly like you know I like
my food the food in the villa was
amazing yes I did put on like quite a
lot of weight at the beginning and then
obviously lost it all when I got a
heartbreaking but you know but you can't
wait this in so say that you want you
don't want models in our time
they put someone like me in and then
you're like why have we got to watch her
on screen she's this she's that you
can't have it both ways
hmm what's the show taught you about
your relationship with your own body
image
I did feel quite self-conscious there at
times I'll admit especially when when
you're feeling low about other things
like just in general when we're not home
sick or tired I'd have a little bit of
her oh he was guys that he was guys
obviously have a lot of time to think
I'm like he was because up with dances
and there it is man your dance from the
same Joanna's really say noise release
thing that's why I don't want everyone
in that be about the beautiful but
personally I like I'm happy and what I'm
happy that but bum has it other foods
have got a bit her being like I'm happy
with that so I wouldn't swap for anyone
else which is such a great thing here
and say yeah cuz I think a lot of people
say you went on that show and it'd
probably be like the least empowering
thing you could do but has it been the
most empowering thing you've done in
your whole life
and now you've got a banging revenge
look exactly and a picture with AJ so
why do Mike when you get so did you see
and the aegis city would couple up with
me and I was like Sunday lunch would be
interesting imagine the chat yes I have
that brother moved onto this floor how
did you and your boyfriend make well
well I mean thank you so much you've
been a very empowering light in the
world babes I feel
[Music]